democrats once again trying to rewrite
the narrative on covet era lockdowns the
head of the nation's second largest
teachers union firing back at critics
who say she flunked the pandemic the
wall street journal blasting randy
weingarten's role in pushing covid
school closures that dramatically harm
the educational progress of the nation's
public school children weingarten
responded to that piece by blaming the
previous administration quote
no teacher i know enjoyed remote and
hybrid learning which pre-pandemic was
championed by betsy devos not one
teacher relished teaching art class via
zoomed to 40 pupils 20 of them in a
classroom and 20 at home while former
president donald trump and his education
secretary ms devos ranted and raved
their successors put the safety measures
in place to get reopening done
but trump's former education secretary
is not taking that attack lightly watch
here
randy weingarten should own up to the
mistakes that they made and the and what
the way they have
harmed kids and harmed families across
the country and yet all she's doing is
blaming everyone else and this is this
is not about teachers this is about
randy weingarten and all of her allies
who continue to control everything with
the democrat party 99 percent of their
contributions going directly to
democrats to do their bidding they have
failed the american people and have
especially failed the kids they're
supposed to be serving today americans
agree with that last part new national
polling shows only 42 percent say they
are completely or somewhat satisfied
with k-12 education and that's down
nearly 10 points since just 2019. do you
remember judge when
the new administration comes in by the
administration and michelle belinsky at
the cdc
says at a press conference
that she thinks kids should go back to
school and the white house within 24
hours said she was speaking in her
personal capacity and then we found the
emails between the union and the cdc
where the the unions were urging schools
to remain closed
what is of course i think we all
remember that so what does it tell us it
tells us that the unions wanted the
schools close but we don't have to just
look at that we can look at the the
whole concept of the democrats trying to
reframe everything like um we're the law
and order party now the republicans are
not law and order and we're all for for
the school's opening up forget the fact
that for the president biden has been
the president for the last year and a
half what i think is interesting is that
we saw parents revolt we saw a governor
get elected in virginia because parents
wanted schools open and i asked someone
to look up the lawsuits in this country
where they were trying to get schools to
open up and they said well there are
some lawsuits that are not just trying
to get the schools to open up there are
some lawsuits where they want the
schools closed i said well let me think
i wonder who was pushing to have the
schools closed who's suing and you know
who's suing the teachers unions to close
the schools so there's no question about
it randy weingarten and the biden
administration can rewrite history or
attempt to all they want but the truth
is that our kids have suffered
tremendously they've had the money to
get the schools ready the schools are
not ready our kids are going to lose
going forward on a global scale and
after the first few months of covid by
the way the catholic schools and the and
the religious schools and charter
schools they were all open so i don't
know who randy weingarten thinks she's
kidding this is too serious an issue to
blame the other guy when it's clearly
randy's they must be seen in there and
the union must be seen in their own
polling that they're taking on water on
this issue that's why she i think she
fought back so hard and also to your
point about the money just to pull this
up jesse 87
of the 122 billion dollars in coveted
spending has gone
unspent like
we american taxpayers were very generous
we said yes okay you need these
resources and they didn't spend the
money it's like the first time the
government hasn't spent money
something's up
what's my best asset
you're here right here it's my memory
but thank you
i remember exactly how this whole thing
went down so 15 days to slow the spread
in april mid
all the schools are out basically until
summer break red states blue states
that's how it went down in the summer
the president donald trump says we need
to really start reopening schools and he
got killed in the press democrats killed
him they said it's dangerous you're
going to kill the children
and in the fall mostly red states opened
up almost all of the red states opened
up and i remember desantis got hammered
for that and desantis would let the
parents choose whether or not they
wanted to mask or not and a lot of the
biggest blue state school districts you
know new york la chicago seattle
they didn't open up they were all remote
and newsom got hit for i think
sacramento school district was totally
remote and he was sending his kids to
private school in in class and then
biden's inaugurated and they had that
little
underhanded move with the union
and they said you know what
we need vaccines if we're going to open
up and then so they jump the line they
get vacs and they still wouldn't open up
and it wasn't until the very end of the
spring semester that almost all of these
blue state school districts began
opening it up so biden can't say that
you're right it's like when they say
republicans wanted to defund the police
it's totally backwards
it is backwards i was going to bring up
glenn younkin as a warning to democrats
because
not only yunkan but in new jersey you
almost had upsets as well that nobody
saw coming and when you did look at the
exit polls a lot of people said
education was the one thing that was
bothering them the most
i don't think there's there's any doubt
you know dana i remember
when public education was a bipartisan
issue you work for a president who
partnered with the most liberal senator
and probably the most effective liberal
senator if not senator of all time teddy
kennedy and they passed the no child
left behind act
i was in congress at the time
and it was one of those moments where a
watershed moment in some ways where you
we went after trying to figure out ways
to help poor kids who you look at the
school districts to drag down
a lot of our our standards not standards
but our standing around the world it's
certainly rural and urban areas where
you have a heavier concentration of poor
kids and that's a problem um we're now
gotten away from the bipartisanship and
i look i wish randy weingarten possessed
all the power that we get we we assign
her if she was the one that could do all
the things we're saying maybe she could
just wave a wand and make everything go
the other way which i don't i don't
believe that she can i take to take a
little umbrage i i look if if you when
donald trump was in office and and
woodward quoted him saying look i didn't
want to tell the country this thing was
so bad because i didn't want to bring
the economy to a halt and people
criticize the president i didn't i
understood where he i kind of sense
where he was coming from and i get a
sense from where these governors and
mayors and others were coming from when
they wanted to go to remote schooling
because there were kids living with
their parents and grandparents there
were people who had
morbidities and people who had
pre-existing conditions and although it
was said that kids couldn't get really
ill the kids brought the virus home and
remember we've come a long way in
knowing about it so i give people a
benefit of doubting some of these things
i do hope that we learn and have learned
a lot about what we did right and what
we did wrong in schools not just from
how we wore masks and so forth i think
the two takeaways i have is not
everyone's going to go to college and we
had this debate around this this thing i
didn't agree with and i think we all
were on the same page about the student
loan forgiveness we got to begin
teaching kids in high school about other
careers and preparing them for after
high school where they can where they
can be trained to do the things that the
country needs and they can make a great
living doing and then finally we talked
a little bit about this jesse before
about how some schools face real
challenges on mondays and tuesdays is
absenteeism because the kids can't clean
their clothes we need community
schooling we're able to bring services
into the schools that these kids need
frankly my two kids who are enormously
blessed and i love them to death but
they're enormously blessed they have
these this apparatus infrastructure
around them that's what we get get to as
well as we think about some of these
really really serious things that our
kids are facing sounds like i think
harold is for the choice the school's
choice i know i know i know you're a big
you're big on that gina martha reported
today that 50 000 students didn't even
return to school in l.a as they came
back as schools are opened i don't know
i have many thoughts you know even as a
little person i like to see the big
picture
and the judge was talking about how the
dems are reframing the reframing law and
ordered education they're reframing and
the republicans have to be reclaiming
good in the sense that we have a
contrast here between an imaginary war
and a real war right on one side biden
and the media are creating this
psychological uh conflict between
trumpies and democracy and yet when you
go outside everybody's happy everybody's
fine meanwhile with actual real people
parents there's a real battle going on
it's an education because the battle
involves their kids this is not a
fabricated conflict you know when you
have lockdowns when you have drag shows
when did all of this happen all of a
sudden they're just showing up
everywhere in middle schools you got the
pronoun police you got to shift from
teaching to lecturing you on race
we're no longer having an emphasis on on
reading and writing but on the racism of
school names so
there is an actual real practical like
uh fact-based conflict going on here
which is an opportunity for the
republicans to reclaim or claim their
right as the parents party you know say
hey we're not gonna call you domestic
terrorists we're not gonna champion
surgery for gender confusion we're not
going to call your kids irrevocably
racist you know take a take a page out
of joe's handbook of fear right scare
the crap out of parents with facts make
it palpable meanwhile when you look at
you know this is going to be a very i'm
going to act like jesse and make a
broad statement
i remember when i was watching the
protests after 2016 when trump won and i
saw the protest
it was a lot of single women it wasn't a
lot of men and the men there they
weren't exquisite specimens let's be
let's face it but i saw a lot of young
angry females and the democratic party
in a way has become the party of young
angry single women right there they
place abortion before babies right it's
their right to have convenience up
to the birth
abortion on demand up to birth that is
not a party for a family that's not a
that's a psychosis if you think you can
abort a child up to the day of birth
that's that's insane that's insane so i
think the republican party should focus
on being the party for parents it's
right there it's a real battle the facts
are there
do it
reclaim reclaim don't get framed don't
get framed reclaim
insane in the membrane start wrapping we
gotta go to break
tone
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now